so erhöht sich die wahrscheinlichkeit
für außerirdisches leben drastisch im
sogenannten brennbaren eis existiert
leben
fachleute haben das methanhydrat im
japanischen meer genauer untersuchen
dabei micro habitate aufgespürt mikroben
in winzigen öl und wasser blasen das
offenbart spektakuläre erkenntnisse
darüber wie und wo in fernen eisigen
welten leben existieren könnte tricks
zum science fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science sie abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
schätzungen zufolge sind es weltweit bis
zu zehn millionen tonnen methan eis die
am meeresgrund am rande der kontinente
liegen es handelt sich um eine feste
verbindung aus wasser und methangas die
nur bei tiefen temperaturen und hohem
druck stabil ist das gas methan entsteht
nur in küstennähe
also da wo viele nährstoffe ins meer
gelangen der mikroorganismen sterben und
sinken zu boden und werden dann mit dem
schlamm begraben das gas geht im meeres
element mit dem sehr kalten wasser eine
extrem dichte mischung ein in der chemie
werden verbindungen in denen wasser
chemische gebunden ist als hydrate
bezeichnet diese sind nur unterhalb
einer wassertiefe von etwa 500 metern zu
finden
bei einer ganz bestimmten temperatur und
das ist übrigens das gefährliche bei
methan steigen die meerestemperaturen
könnte das methan in die atmosphäre
gelangen
methan ist dort unten in der stadt am
wasser eingelagert wobei die
wassermoleküle das methan vollständig
umschließen
man kann sich das vorstellen wie ein
käfig aus wassermolekülen in denen sich
die gasmoleküle befinden in einem
kubikmeter methanhydrat sind bis zu 160
kubikmeter gas eingespeichert einige
staaten wollen diese gashydrat vorkommen
erschließen und als energiequelle nutzen
denn wird methanhydrat entzündet
entsteht eine lange brennende flamme
heißt also wir haben es mit einem
hochwertigen gas zur energiegewinnung zu
tun doch bislang fehlt es an
fördertechnik und das ist vielleicht
auch gut so denn eben noch ist unklar
welche folgen methanhydrat abbau für die
ökosysteme der ozeane und für das klima
mit sich bringen würde methan ist ja
eben ein klimagas wie co2 seine wirkung
ist nur noch heftiger ein forschungsteam
hat das methan
hat im japanischen meer das als randmeer
des pazifischen ozeans in ostasien gilt
genauer untersucht die fachleute konnten
hierbei eine überraschende entdeckung
machen in winzigen eingeschlossenen
blasen spürten die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler aus japan so
genannte micro habitate auf gemeint sind
damit lebensräume von mikroben dabei
hatte das forschungsteam eigentlich ein
ganz anderes ziel ist gegen den
fachleuten nämlich vielmehr um
methanhydrat und sein potenzial als
energiequelle dazu hatten sie dafür
drahtig schmolzen und das methangas das
dabei endlich genauer analysiert dabei
spürten sie ein merkwürdiges pulver auf
mit kugelförmigen bestandteilen die
einem dunklen kern im zentrum aufwiesen
dieser fund überraschten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
so dass sie weitere analysen an gingen
mit hilfe von neuartigen
analysetechniken wurde dann schnell klar
dass in der direkten umgebung von
methanhydrat öl abgebaut wird heißt also
im klartext trotz des extrem hohen
drucks und der eiskalten temperaturen
existierte also leben dass spuren
hinterlässt das autorenteam schreibt
konkret von sogenannten bakteriums spd
diese bakterien bauen komplexe erdöl
makromoleküle ab die sich als
verunreinigung in den gelblichen
methanhydrat befinden mit zunehmender
tiefe nimmt der biologische abbau der
aktuellen analyse zufolge ab und genau
das ist nach ansicht des forschungsteams
mit der mikrobiellen aktivität von
bagdad dts vereinbar und das obwohl
einzig salzwasser und schweröl als
nahrungsquelle genutzt werden kann dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher
glänzender das methan in methanhydrat
wird bekanntermaßen gebildet wenn
mikroben organische substanzen auf dem
meeresboden abbauen
wir hätten aber nie erwartet dass dort
mikroben wachsen und dieses ferro ide
produzieren während sie die ganze zeit
in winzigen kalten dunklen taschen im
salzwasser und öl isoliert sind das
liefert uns faszinierende hinweise auf
die potenzielle existenz von leben in
ähnlich anderen exotischen welt die
fachleute selbst also sind äußerst
überrascht über diese neuen erkenntnisse
dazu ergänzt der wissenschaftler stephen
boden der ebenfalls an der aktuellen
studie beteiligt war
es ändert zweifellos meine ansicht auf
dinge all diese kalten planeten an den
ländern jedes planetensystems könnten
winzigen mikro habitate beherbergen in
denen die proben ihre eigenen winzigen
lebensräume schaffen so wie wir es hier
entdeckt haben und es gibt noch etwas
anderes absolut krasses mit bakterien
bakterien als datenspeicher anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar diesen
kanal krieg substanzen fiction bis dann
bleibt dran